olá pessoal
os estragos aqui uma armadilha tão
conhecida pelo povo brasileiro que era
pouca e por fazer esta armadilha muito
eficiente
vocês poderão usar apanhar o ele os
esquilos
eu digo que nos roedores mas atenção
você só podem usar esta armadilha é em
caso de emergência
quando a nossa vida atender mesmo
naquilo que vem do carro que vocês
possam a vir com uma lista pronta
seguinte esqueci de dizer e prestar uma
ilha vocês vão precisar de uma entre
mais de dois metros de fio
caso você não tenha uma mão quando
estiverem província foram simples a
tiros cascas das árvores que vocês já
não come e rolar ela fica bem resistente
e além disso a sistran cortar paulo de
dores
cada vez mais quente
deixamos os maiores em baixos bacaninha
em cima você vai com desta maneira bem
simples até que acorda fique bem
esticada e que a caixa fique bem forte
se você quiser que fique mais alta corte
determine sua administração não ia dar
pra apanhar nem colina que é bem
pequenininha só para alguns pacientes
contaminados após demonstrar ação
ninguém tem que usar isto te pego só em
caso de emergência pronto nos falar com
ele lá pra cá o nosso quintal apanhar aí
o gato vizinho o xixi lula ou antes de
anunciarem que ela tem nos pronto podem
fazer treinar mas não passa disso
agora estou a fazer o som está muito bem
quando eu faço as armadilhas e então
fica muito mal
a caixa já foi feita e agora para o
gatilho
encontrar um paulo em forma de y não
disputaria a fiar
tem que ter mais sério além disso é só
um y mais um cliente fio um paulo cumpre
iene e uma peça lhe madeira
vocês podem ver ela mais à frente e
mostrar melhor perto até simples gatilho
o risco pisa no palco caixa em cima fica
magoado não só devia ter uns meros não
faça um gesto é até o próximo